over the years science fiction movies
have launched
more than a few budding actors into
super stardom
and nowadays being cast in a tentpole
sci-fi flick
is almost guaranteed to launch your
hollywood career
sadly however things don't always turn
out so well just ask these guys
though she had no prior acting
experience carrie hen beat out hundreds
of other candidates for the role of newt
in aliens
we better get back because it'll be dark
soon and they mostly come at night
mostly and entered the production a
complete unknown
but before long the whole world knew who
she was as
aliens grossed over 130 million dollars
worldwide
the film and characters like newt were
pretty much everywhere
it was the perfect launch pad for hen to
pursue a long and successful career as
an actor
but to this day aliens remains hens only
acting credit
hence sparse filmography was a
deliberate choice on her part
after finishing principal photography on
aliens she decided to opt out of
hollywood altogether
and ended up pursuing a career as an
educator in 2000 she earned her degree
in liberal studies and child development
and today she teaches 4th graders in
northern california
while hannah has made a conscious
decision to forego an acting career
she still appears on panels at fan
conventions and frequently keeps in
touch with her alien's co-star sigourney
weaver
speaking about her friendship with
weaver hen told wired she took me under
her wings when we were filming because
i was so inexperienced i can't describe
my relationship with her because
she's more than just a friend what you
see on the screen is genuinely how we
feel about each other
hen may have left the world of film but
her enduring friendship with weaver
proves aliens has had a lasting impact
on her life
one that still affects her to this day
linda hamilton never intended for her
career to be defined by her work as
sarah connor in the terminator
movies as she told the new york times
did i think i was going to become an
action adventure star
not once i was going to be a
shakespearean actress
and with terminator it all took a left
turn
nonetheless both terminator and
terminator 2 judgement day
cemented hamilton's reputation as an
action movie star
unfortunately hamilton wasn't enamored
with the role she was offered in the
wake of terminator 2 success
she recalled nobody looked at it like
she can do anything
instead it was she's going to eat us
alive
people really didn't know what to do
with me since her lead role in dante's
peak in 1997
hamilton has primarily kept a low
profile as an actor
preferring instead to enjoy a kind of
semi-retirement from acting
that retirement was briefly broken by
hamilton in 2019 however when she
reprised her role as sarah connor in
terminator
dark fate though intended to spawn a
number of sequels
fate's 261.1 million dollar
worldwide box office hall put those
follow-up plans on ice
hamilton for one isn't interested in
returning again to play sarah connor
speaking to people magazine she said i
would be quite happy
to never return i would really love to
be done
peyton christensen is most famous for
taking on the role of anakin skywalker
in star wars attack of the clones and
revenge of the sith
while he earned considerable praises for
his dramatic performances in films such
as
shattered glass his turns in the star
wars prequels were widely reviled
he even ended up winning a golden
raspberry for worse supporting actor
twice for his portrayal of the jedi
turned sith lord
i don't like sand it's coarse and
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere
the high profile status of star wars
movies eventually led christensen to
taking a break from hollywood
he later told the los angeles times i
guess i felt like i had this great thing
in star wars that provided all these
opportunities
and gave me a career but it all kind of
felt a little two-handed to me i didn't
want to go through life feeling like i
was just riding a wave
since the star wars prequels wrapped up
christensen has only appeared in a
handful of movies
such as 90 minutes in heaven and jumper
and perhaps surprisingly
christensen's main focus has been
running his own farm
he tells the toronto star it's a hobby
but i want to have the appearance of
being a proper farmer
i'm trying to figure it out it's all new
to me but i would eventually like it to
be a fully operational farm
with livestock and different crops
when he sat down with variety to discuss
his latest film species
producer frank mancuso jr said it's not
a movie that calls for stars
we're going to try and put as much money
as we can below the line and allow the
effects and the creature to be the
highlights of the film
this approach led to newcomer natasha
henstridge securing the role of the
alien human hybrid still
in species the movie even ended up
grossing a respectable 113 million
dollars worldwide
sadly henstridge struggled to escape the
shadow of sill in her future work
speaking with revue graveyard the actor
said there are things involved in being
remembered for a particular role that
people have a hard time letting go of
and when it comes to making other
projects that can be tough
this challenge was reflected in her
first post-species endeavors
such as maximum risk and species 2
neither of which garnered much in the
way of box office or critical success
since 2008 henstridge has only appeared
in a handful of independent movies and a
few
tv shows but as it turns out typecasting
may not have been the only reason she
kept out of the spotlight
in november 2017 she was one of six
women in a los
angeles times story to accuse filmmaker
brett ratner of sexual harassment and
misconduct
alex pettifer's career as a leading man
kicked off with a pair of 2011 sci-fi
films
the first was im number four a cosmic
take on the twilight formula of a
fantastical being falling in love with a
mortal human
he received at least some praise for his
work in the role with the guardian
noting that the pretty glowery alex
pettifer plays a good extraterrestrial
unfortunately number four never became
the next twilight
it was released to theaters in february
2011 to a worldwide box office total of
just under 150 million dollars
pettifer's other 2011 sci-fi movie in
time fared only slightly better in the
box office
these commercial struggles led to
pettifer's career as a sci-fi leading
man being short-lived
save for the netflix series the island
and the upcoming thriller warning
pettifer has avoided the genre entirely
since 2011
focusing on independent fare ever since
the release of endless love in february
2014.
pettifer's shift away from the sci-fi
fair and major hollywood productions was
a conscious choice too
in an interview with v-man he said i was
disillusioned by hollywood at the time
but now i've come to accept that's just
the way things are
it's called show business not show art
paul verhoeven's starship troopers was
always going to need the right leading
man to pull off its biting satirical
tone
as verhoeven told the av club it will be
playing with fascism or fascist imagery
to point out certain aspects of american
society
of course the movie is about let's all
go to war and let's all die
that meant that the lead character
johnny rico would need to be played by
somebody who looks like they had walked
right out of an army recruitment poster
so who better for the part than casper
van dien a man who once recalled to
people magazine that his high school
classmates called him kendall
van dien fit the intended aesthetic of
starship troopers like a glove
unfortunately it proved far more
challenging for van dien to fit into
other successful leading man roles
after troopers he headlined box office
duds like the omega code and sanctimony
by 2006 he was starring in projects as
loki as the hallmark channel movie the
curse of king tut's tomb in recent years
van dien has shifted his focus from
leading man roles to directing
helming a number of movies including
sleeping beauty and the last bid
he told anthem magazine i would love to
direct more i hope i get to do that
again in the future
i would love to direct something that's
a little more personal to me or an
action movie
saffron burrow's initial foray into
sci-fi was less than ideal
she played the co-lead opposite freddy
prince jr and wing commander
which received scathing reviews even
from its own stars
prince himself told movie line i can't
stand wing commander
i can't watch one scene of that movie
but burroughs would make another stab at
headlining sci-fi movies with the lead
role of dr susan mcallister in deep blue
sea
a shark thriller that was significantly
better received than wing commander
in the wake of deep blue sea burrows
rarely returned to sci-fi storytelling
save for the occasional guest role such
as the recurring part she took on agents
of shield
in recent years burroughs has balanced
her recurring tv roles with her lifelong
commitment to activism and progressive
politics
she tells the guardian i do have a
penchant for the bureaucracy of union
conferences motions and speeches
certainly there's a huge amount of
nitty-gritty that some people would find
tedious but i might enjoy
between the terminator aliens and the
abyss michael bean was a prominent face
in sci-fi movies during the 1980s
it doesn't feel pity or remorse
or fear and it absolutely will not stop
ever to hear bean tell it however he was
never really a movie star
as he explained to the hollywood
reporter people always talk about me
being an 80s star
i was not an 80s star bruce willis was
an 80s star
tom cruise was an 80s star those guys
were making 20 million dollars a picture
i never even got 1 million i kind of
liked it that way
in the wake of those big hits bean opted
to slow things down
rather than pursue hollywood a-list
status over the last 30 years he's only
appeared in a handful of major films
such as tombstone and planet terror
rather than headline an endless
succession of star vehicles he's
consciously chosen to put his family
life first
bean says the amount of movies bruce
willis makes i don't see how you can
live a normal life where you see your
kids all the time
you're taking them to school and
baseball practice and you're coaching
their teams
you're in their lives while being kept
out of the spotlight in recent years his
role in the second season of the
mandalorian sees him finally returning
to the world of sci-fi
the genre that first helped him kick off
his big screen career
tj miller is a surprise to have become a
movie star as anybody else
as he once told the hollywood reporter
i'm not an actor i'm a comedian
i hoodwinked hollywood into giving me a
career in this
that career began with miller playing
mostly unseen camera operator
hud in the sci-fi horror film
cloverfield and in the years following
he was a common sight and sci-fi fair
he played the role of weasel in the two
deadpool movies fred and big hero 6
and iroc in ready player 1. miller's
various sci-fi roles frequently see the
actor taking on the role of comic relief
for example on his casting in deadpool
miller told usa today
the producers all asked if there was
anyone out there who looks like his
superhero power was spilling mustard on
his shirt
and each of them each at once said tj
miller
but miller's film career has been
derailed by a number of real world
scandals
these have included allegedly sending a
transphobic email to a film critic
as well as allegations of sexual assault
and workplace misconduct
on top of that miller was arrested in
april 2018
for allegedly calling it a fake bomb
threat these events have led to his
career opportunities dwindling
including losing out on a role in a
potential x-force movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you